so kimberly so on the new song someone
told me that you guys
used mouth trumpets and on the song and
i can actually hear it especially at the
end
one of the last ones so care to explain
how that happened and was wine beer or
whiskey involved
absolutely
i can't do that did y'all all do it
yeah we considered leaving it like that
you can hear the mouth trumpet at the
end though at the very end
that's the best part and it's like i
want to go to that party where at the
end i feel like i'm so awesome i can
play a trumpet with my mouth
well we were gonna keep the mouth
trumpets but uh
we had to we decided to add jacob from
the brummies a great little band
uh and he played trumpet and on the
record so we were like we gotta have
both
i love it the vibe is so cool guys like
how this song starts out it's like where
is this going like and then it
how it ends it literally is so cool
that's what i love about you
you're so adventurous and you play with
different genres and it's just really
it's really really cool to be a fan of
you and how y'all are unafraid of that
and
it's nice to go on the ride with y'all